will the Republican party is finally
behaving rationally Republicans are
panicking that the now multiple arrests
of failed former president twice
impeached twice indicted Donald Trump
may actually Boomerang on them and be
damaging big picture there's an
interesting article in the hill by
Alexander Bolton called Republicans fear
Trump legal woes will Boomerang on them
Senate Republicans are worried that
Trump's legal troubles will create a
major headwind for Republican candidates
in 2024 they say the battle between the
justice department and Trump who pleaded
not guilty Tuesday just as his
unsubstantiated claims that the 2020
election was stolen became a Prominent
Point of debate in last year's primaries
they worry Trump's dominance of the
media Spotlight will turn off swing
voters especially Suburban women and
hurt their chances of taking back the
senate or protecting their small house
majority the article goes on to include
a number of quotes from different
Republicans this is a logical reaction
to what is going on now there is a group
of people that is choosing to narrowly
focus only on the presidential race and
we will look at the polling in the
presidential race a little bit later
today
you could convince yourself and maybe
others if you look only at the
presidential race that it is quite
binary and it doesn't have any
trickle-down effect what is happening
with Donald Trump let me tell you what I
mean by that you could look at the Trump
arrests and look at the Republican
primary and say to yourself listen
if Trump's arrests hurt Trump someone
else will win the primary and then that
person will face Joe Biden and they
might win or they might lose and it will
have nothing to do with what is going on
with Trump in other words the context is
Trump's legal troubles will only affect
who is the Republican nominee and beyond
that it will not have any broader impact
on the Republican party there are two
problems with that relatively narrow
Focus problem number one is that indeed
if Trump is leading the Republican
primary for several more months but then
he's arrested a third time and
potentially arrested a fourth time and
then it becomes clear he can't really
campaign because he's just going from
Courthouse to courthouse and Ron
DeSantis or someone else ends up winning
the primary the impact of that last
minute Collapse by Donald Trump doesn't
end with the Republican primary and
there is the belief and I believe it is
a war warranted belief that if such a
shake-up were to take place it would
weaken whoever is the eventual
Republican nominee against Joe Biden so
that's one way in which thinking of the
Trump arrests only is relevant
to the Republican primary is wrong but
what Republicans are increasingly
concerned about now is very serious
which is that this entire circus
atmosphere and Sideshow nature of what
is going on which also by the way
includes some Republican candidates
saying I would pardon Trump and others
saying I wouldn't and this just becoming
the circus that it is it may just be
very bad for random Republican Senators
seeking re-election for random members
of the House of Representatives some who
are supporters of trump and some who are
not that it will create a broader
problem for any Republican that is
running in November of 24 including
simply that the Trump Fiasco might
reduce turnout and make some voters stay
home who would otherwise vote to
re-elect some of these Republicans it's
too early to know whether that fear is
backed by data but intuitively it makes
a ton of sense we'll leave that question
there and now I want to look at a little
bit at some new National polling one of
our sponsors today is relief band relief
band is the number one FDA cleared
anti-nausea wristband clinically proven
to effectively prevent nausea and
vomiting relief band is a type of
therapy called transdermal
neuromodulation acue stimulation and in
really simple terms it's just a band you
wear on your wrist that sends a gentle
pulse to the part of your nervous system
that regulates nausea and there's been
growing research showing that relief ban
can help with nausea from motion
sickness from pregnancy and from all
sorts of other situations and a number
of studies suggest relief band can help
with nausea after surgery in conjunction
with medication many people use relief
band for nausea from anxiety or
migraines when you feel sick on a car or
plane or a boat it's simple it's safe
it's drug free and there are no side
effects relief band has an A plus rating
from the Better Business Bureau with
over one hundred thousand satisfied
customers online it's just a brand you
can trust you can go and read the
reviews let relief band help you make
nausea a thing of the past you'll get 20
off plus free shipping when you go to
reliefband.com and use the code Pacman
at checkout the link is in the
description